[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
that coke had to be in my pocket at 8
o'clock i would fall apart at the seams
yeah and i would put in my little drug
pocket yeah and it would stay there
unbothered
a little baggy waterproof in case the
[ __ ] rain came i guess the floods
came in case you
got biblical yeah this don't break out
of it yeah i still in case louisiana all
over again
i'm gonna tie a floating wave at the
airport [ __ ] i'm here
dude how great would that be you're on
the news they're like showing you and
you're just down there
like how many videos are there of the
news during a katrina where there's
just a bunch of brothers just blowing a
[ __ ] blunt and they [ __ ] couldn't
put it on
and just yelling up you can't stop me
bitching
so it's an island when you you come from
a [ __ ] island
there's gotta be incest somewhere along
the line i don't think i'd ever do
incest man even if i think i had the
hottest hottest fam family member
ever bro ever think about that though
dude
listen i don't want to talk about incest
on the church though okay
we got [ __ ] boundaries here we can't
be talking about incest
i had a cousin i wanted to [ __ ] too as a
kid
nobody [ __ ] nobody i thought you
just said we couldn't talk about it but
i'll never forget one night like
we were at this cuban dude's house and
we were snorting coke and she was
sitting there with me and this cuban
dude goes
not for nothing but your wife doesn't
say much i go she's deaf
she wasn't deaf she just didn't speak
spanish oh yeah so the guy looks at me
goes he's all cooked up he's like i
don't know if you know this
i work with deaf people in cuba right
right
so she's like i'm like talk to her in
death language and he's like
and he's doing all these noises and [ __ ]
and also she's like looking at
me and i go she goes what do i do and i
go just draw some hang singles and [ __ ]
with them
and she's like and i'll say he looks and
he goes
i never studied that language
lee man dude it's so funny you know
sometimes when i i'm not even joking
about
when i need to think about something
good dude i think about lee man
oh thank you that means a lot yeah i
think about you man i think you think
about you
to laugh you mean just the stuff you say
randomly
like i just want to hang out and like
listen to what you say during the day to
yourself i just i feel like it's
hysterical this conversation is getting
creepy right here already
well you just farted on me i think we
might be able to
just get on oh yeah i know what you're
talking about
they say hey you know the boy over there
a little little give a [ __ ] visa
i don't care either bruh i'll let you
hang off my dick like a [ __ ] mountain
cave oh i would never let lisa
not you guys but i don't have the same
relationship with him yeah but you're
still friends you can't i'm friends with
him
i wouldn't [ __ ] him i'll let him touch
my dick a little you know saying down
around the holidays bro just to make his
day oh he's a prison ham this guy bro i
[ __ ] love that boy you know how much
money i told
we won't walk and leave one night how
much money we can make with lee on the
inside oh my god just sitting on
people's laps
dealing cards rubbing their dick yeah
i'm glad we're bringing this back
you can't just sit on someone's lap but
they're not going to let it end at just
the lap sitting bro
they're not in prison because they they
gary indiana you're an eight bro
a warm female and gary indiana dog
you're a female hey
baby man i got a guy that'll pay 10 g's
for you to put a wig on
oh yeah special type of podcast and just
mug his dick with your [ __ ] neck he's
already ripped me a letter
what does that even mean mugging dick
did now with your mom being so tough was
it like
did was it tough to feel like affection
from her because sometimes like my mom's
a hard worker right my mom delivered
you know she's a delivery woman you know
she delivered newspapers when i was a
kid she delivers magazines now
um she's always had a [ __ ] van you
know now she's got my
her husband he has alzheimer's don't
even know he's in the van he's with her
every day just [ __ ]
bouncing around in the [ __ ] passenger
seat
she had to get a [ __ ] second seatbelt
installed for him because he [ __ ]
would kind of sleep he's getting little
he would slip
out of the [ __ ] first one and now
she's got him just
basically in a [ __ ] straight jacket
just bouncing around he has no clue
where he is
just delivering [ __ ] news on wheels
every day you know
i think he's about 90 you know your mom
still does this my mom still does it
dude
and here's the worst part bruh she got a
good deal on this van right
my mom likes a good deal and she got a
good deal on this van has no win
none of the side or back windows bro so
her [ __ ] gps is the lord bruh she
just [ __ ] bouncing around he's got
him in the thing
that and that [ __ ] denny's i saw were
you with me when we saw what's his name
in there
i don't think so yeah you with me when
we saw who they got the braves
improvement oh he goes there all the
time
that's a that's a swing and then he's
over there yeah i just don't go in there
at night because that's
you're born to get shot after that
denny's you might go to vegas to a
country concert brother
when you go to denny's after ten
nowadays you might as well sign up for
the next country [ __ ] contest
and [ __ ] whatever stand real close to
the window and wave this time
dude this uh
bro i used to do this bit about denny's
how much i hated denny's right
um it's almost special right so anyway
i was like i wish somebody would shoot
up a [ __ ] denny's right that's what i
would say
dude some kid puts in the comments he
goes
man he puts a cl a link to a youtube
clip he goes man
my dad actually got shot up at a [ __ ]
tennis he goes
somebody walked in with a gun and shot
everybody in the place
one star he goes but i still love this
bit that you do
and that was beautiful bruh here i am
joking about it he said it really
happened he lost his father
right next to a [ __ ] grill bro right
next to a griddle you know what you got
you know two brothers back there [ __ ]
sword fighting with spatulas i probably
hopped up on [ __ ]
methamphetamines you know not knowing
they're gonna lose their job
to the [ __ ] mexican guy sitting at
the bar you know
unbelievable man but that's god dude
that kid came and he was just positive
man there's a couple places where i go
late night
and i'm like like one night me lee and
becky went to denny's on a [ __ ] on a
on a [ __ ] sunday night after a
podcast
and we were having a good time but the
whole time i was like squatting
under the bush by that window because
the windows on burbank boulevard
i want to be a [ __ ] all right shoot up
at denny's i'm sitting there having
[ __ ] a salad
and something with my friend here
and becky's sitting counterclockwise so
she gets it right now
we got to bury becky with a hat on with
a tent planet [ __ ]
with a chef hat on josh
[Laughter]
oh armor we're walking around just
hanging out you know drinking
you know havana club you know or
whatever you know people
what year is this this is 2002. so
just walking around and uh so there's
some people hanging out in an alley that
are kind of dancing and partying a
little bit so we go over there and we
think it's like a family it's like a
birthday cake and stuff so we're singing
you know cumpleanos everybody's having a
nice time we think oh we're
you know we're in a different country
we're celebrating some guy's birthday
then one of the dudes at the birthday
starts eating this lady out [ __ ] just
we're like this and we're like oh these
are these are escorts like we didn't
know we thought it was like a family
and next thing we're all dancing with
these [ __ ] ladies and everything it's
like a grandmother like a [ __ ]
birthday party
next thing you know one of the guys goes
down with the lady's waist a little low
and [ __ ] starts eating her [ __ ]
right there i'm like what the
[ __ ] bro welcome to cuba yeah this [ __ ]
is [ __ ]
awesome i was talking to somebody last
weekend i went to a party
and there was boats and next you know
there was a girl [ __ ] a guy on the
boat i didn't know what to do
get in there yeah jump in or [ __ ]
call
there 911 you're gonna stand and let
somebody get that dick sucked
at least go and put a finger in there at
least
cheer for him you know my buddy how many
nights we leave here
dying of hunger you and i one in the
morning sometimes me and him he's cross
side
yeah this guy if i at two in the morning
if i gonna lean listen i got a
sandwich coming over here just jiggle my
balls i guarantee i'll confuse him for
ten minutes
he'll be sitting there confused i don't
know i got this jiggle his balls
i washed my hands i've done worse i got
a hand job from a chinese shake one side
[ __ ] place was so expensive i
couldn't even sleep you know like 600
bucks i'm not [ __ ]
i'll stay awake and watch the money go
by you know at least enjoy to
walk around the room this thing's six
hundred dollars a [ __ ] night
you know they had uh like nine light
switches in there dude it's like a
[ __ ]
i don't know where i was it was insane
you could spend 40 minutes just [ __ ]
turning on all the lights it's [ __ ]
crazy
it is man it gets really interesting
let's take a another couple calls if you
don't mind
i got a piece and we'll take one more
we'll get the [ __ ] out of here you got
it let's do it
suggestions i can give up joey with some
good advice or some suggestions i can
give my wife
for her first psychedelic trip
appreciate it man love you guys
whoa it's like i live in an aquarium you
see that [ __ ] guy right there
first thing for a psychedelic trip is
for his wife for his wife
just make it easy for her but then [ __ ]
with her once she's high
yeah oh wait i think you told me a story
about this one time yeah when my first
wife in san francisco in 85
we took some grateful dead ass and went
to a party i was very nice to her
you said her stepdad was at the airport
i kept telling her
don't you have to pick your father up at
the airport and she's like let's go
and then she go what time is he coming
in i mean i had this poor girl going
then there was a poster of bruce lee on
the wall oh and i kept going
looking at bruce lee going don't say
nothing to her no no
come on bro don't don't talk don't say
nothing to her
she can't handle it she would look at me
like what's he saying i don't know
don't listen to him i put that girl
that's the girl that i wrote the letter
i bet it is because i put it through
death in africa they hit you with a
[ __ ] pipe bro if they love you
just take a win for that fight i'm not
gonna take a whiff of your part that's
come on
get a little air appetizer bruh treat
your nose that is tremendous treat your
snout to some of that [ __ ] free booty
pasta bruh bruh
i took my tits around yeah you could
feel the beads
i remember getting off the plane in
miami the next morning and my pants were
[ __ ] wet
and the waitress the the stewardess
would just walk in the halls look at me
and give me a water
she knew how [ __ ] up i was
dude my buddy and his brother used to
get so [ __ ] up on coke in miami then
they go
to the hotel room put on diapers bro
cause they kept [ __ ] themselves and
just go back down to the [ __ ] dance
floor
just partying with diapers full of [ __ ]
brothers dancing and they could dance
bro i mean these boys could [ __ ]
dance who wants to dance with somebody
smells like [ __ ]
but i think they stop
that's what it's like to be uh i think
they were latinos for sure
to get coked up with a dude that used to
put a string on his wrist
and the string would go to the doorknob
so if he tried to open the doorknob
his string bryce would get high with
some crazy people yeah
i used to get high with his brother who
was bald and his brother would be
talking to him
like we'd be doing coke like yeah yeah
and also he'd go
like what they go and he smacked himself
because he kept thinking flies
on his head he would smack himself 80
[ __ ] times a night
and we would laugh at every [ __ ] time
and after he'd smack himself he'd go
[Laughter]
bro he used to put balloons he lived on
the 34th floor
i had another friend kurt he's dead now
rest in peace good good dude
he used to get so paranoid that he would
put little parachutes
on his cocaine so if the cops came he
would throw it out the window
and the little parachutes would fly i
mean that's the [ __ ] that was the 80s
you know that's
god daddy's is good bro you ever noticed
when you learned something about
somebody you didn't know you know
like you see somebody and they're like a
lawyer or something but then you realize
they're like a sorcerer or something or
they do
shady [ __ ] or you see them like ballroom
dancing
and you're like this [ __ ] guy
ballroom dances
i always that that always takes my brain
a minute or if you see a big big person
and they got their stomach stapled and
now
dude i was at a pool one time and i used
to work on this farm in the summer times
outside in natchez mississippi and they
had uh
and this dude don blankenstein was the
pool guy every year right and he come
out there
and i'd keep an eye on him because the
dude weighed probably seven or eight
hundred pounds bro
you know what i'm saying he broke the
gate every time he come in he [ __ ] he
was the lifeguard
he gets in the pool trust me nobody's
drowning all the waters out and the
[ __ ] kid who's sick is laying right
there
no he was the thick he was the guy who
came to put the the cleaner in the pool
and so but he'd open the gate run every
time he'd walk through it and bring both
sides of the gate down like he was just
uh
he was gonna die soon you know when you
saw him you know so you treated him well
and that's one thing i like sometimes
about seeing huge people it reminds you
how to treat other people
because you're like oh this person isn't
going to be alive very long so you would
be extra nice to him and so but then don
one summer i'm out there laying by the
pool
and uh and this skinny guy comes in
you know he could have fit through the
gate with 90 of his [ __ ]
you know quintuplets or whatever and
he comes through the gate and i'm like
and he keeps talking to me
and i'm thinking the guy's kind of a you
know peppermint hunter bruh you know
what i'm saying a little tender
and it turns out it's don blanken uh
blankenstein he got
the stomach thing and he lost all the
weight
and he was a different person though he
wasn't the same
i don't know it wasn't the same and our
relationship was never the same as when
he lost as when he lost the weight
[Music]
ain't no right way it's just the wrong
way i know